foreign
[Music]
ladies text sorry ladies text the person
you're sleeping with and say why aren't
we officially together I saw a couple of
these screenshot their responses to this
tweet
ah Brad cool all right so obviously I'm
going to read it as a conversation
why aren't we officially together
oh my goodness you're doing the Lonnie
thing
um we haven't we haven't known each
other that long I guess reply I need to
unfollow you on Twitter reply but I
would definitely hop onto the Whirlwind
romance with you complete complete with
the kissing in the rain scene she said
rainwater has germs and we both fall
sick afterwards love the opportunity of
kissing you though
swear yeah
this is wait this is someone she's
already bagging
all right all right
water has germs has jobs she went
straight to the point shut up I couldn't
I couldn't receive that also it would
embarrass me that I've said oh we have
to do up Rain kisses yeah yeah rainbow
has germs I'll be like why did I even
give that to her oh bro my what's that
picture will be gray on her side yeah
because I blocked her because I can't
continue conversation anymore
my profile picture will be great yeah
yeah moving on Moving On by the time she
said would love the opportunity to it's
just one thing one tick brother I don't
exist in your life anymore
must be great
that's too funny
cool why aren't we officially together
you said you have commitment issues
reply okay
that was it okay okay
that's jokes don't jump on Trends if
you're not ready to see it through okay
why are we efficient
you said you have a commitment she
fought I did say that okay I was lying
wow okay she bit the bullet
why aren't we officially together the
[ __ ] is wrong with you
sweat is that the whole thing that's it
the [ __ ] is wrong with you
that was it she didn't even entertained
the back and forth I don't feel like
these women have taken into
consideration the conversations that
they've had prior
of course not they're just doing it
sounds like these men have tried their
hardest big man I tried to ask you a
month so bad times you knew what was
wrong don't want to see me in public you
knew what I was on the audacity to text
me why aren't we officially together the
[ __ ] is wrong with you
told you to
you're doing this to me now because
Alani told you to right in the hope that
she might [ __ ] share this tweet
your mum don't do this do this to me
when you know I love you don't do this
to me
why aren't we officially together
officially because we would kill one
another
facts facts
this one's waited all right we
officially together
because you're married to another man is
that who you're looking cute for in your
stories
no
that's who you're looking cute for in
your stories your your husband
why aren't we officially together
because you're married
is this are you are you in fact yeah
literally what what is the [ __ ] is wrong
with you yeah like what the actual [ __ ]
is wrong with you bro is it all because
an influencer said
us against them
wow
why are we officially together what do
you mean exactly what I said we are
though that's all I needed to know
that's his girl why aren't we officially
together
you're my girl I couldn't read that
because I'll be like who's this for
eign immediately
why are we officially together what
expired vodka are you drinking this
evening
then this sweets me because men
don't have time for this [ __ ] don't
we don't it's time for nothing [ __ ]
you don't brother we literally don't
women love to play games they love it
why aren't we together
get the [ __ ] off my phone immediately
yeah [ __ ] to do and bills to pay stop
asking me dumb questions I'm a Hunter
I'm a Hunter and a provider don't don't
block my attention span with this
[ __ ]
oh god oh that's so funny why aren't we
officially together who is this
jokes
[ __ ] that's funny that's [ __ ] funny
all right why are we officially together
he replied with like side eye emoji she
said answer me he replied you've met my
family and you're saying why are we
officially together what do you want a
speech and a prize giving day
surprise giving day
he's he's the most African brand the
most African Brown
the most African brand price giving day
the most products
[ __ ] that's funny bro a speech and a
prize-giving day [ __ ] it up
why aren't we officially together are
you trying to give both of us a headache
oh are fair play facts and fair play
fair play why aren't we officially
together this one needs to be talked
about in person
I wonder how to respond to that sit down
yeah fam I wouldn't know if I'm the yeah
I wouldn't know how to respond to that
what do you actually mean there's a
conversation we need to have in person
we need to discuss this face-to-face
her heart sung I'd be like sorry
yeah she's bending him
Raw
Jesus Christ why aren't we officially
together because the hoe's gonna get mad
and you can't fight and she replied
facts and she put disability
facts bro the hoes are going to get mad
and you can't fight
last one
why are we officially together
sorry why aren't we official I official
with someone I can't [ __ ] without a
condom you're dreaming
foreign
[Music]
your dream
[Music]
s